[Music]
5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well we got another
viewer email about traffic signals and
this is the exact same solution for
everyone
Jill writes the signal for the ramp from
westbound Silverado Ranch to go south on
I-15 is no longer synced when you're
going West on Silverado Ranch the
freeway you get stuck at the first light
you come to and by the time you get to
the second light the left turn Signal's
already turned red you can't make the
green light like you used to be able to
I see people running that second red
light all the time
well Jill the Regional Transportation
Commission oversees thousands of traffic
signals all around southern Nevada and
while most of them work pretty well the
RTC knows that some of them don't and
they encourage anyone with a problem
like yours to reach out and let them
know here's the phone number
702-901-8400 you don't have to grab a
pen or pencil to get that number just
look for the online version of this
store it's on our website 8newsnow.com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you know you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com